hello guys this is Luxur from simply
learn and welcome to this tutorial on
Java objected programming or OOP
concepts this is a part of a Java
tutorial series where we will be
covering everything you need to know to
master Java this is what we are going to
learn today first we'll get to know what
Java OOP means and all its concepts then
we look into each of the concepts one by
one first abstraction then encapsulation
polymorphism and lastly inheritance we
will see a Java code on IntelliJ for
each of these concepts so let's get
started so what is Java OOP OOP means
object-oriented programming OOP is a
method to design a program using classes
and objects that relate to the real
world we have four concepts of Java OOP
abstraction encapsulation polymorphism
and inheritance now let's look at each
of them one by one first let's talk
about abstraction abstraction means
showing the relevant details and hiding
all the backend or internal details
the syntax for abstraction is on your
screen we use abstract keyword to make a
class or method abstract now let's take
an example for admission to a college
the information that is relevant are
name address parents name and high
school marks favorite sports food or
movie are irrelevant for admission but
this information may be relevant to join
a club in college now let's have a look
at an example to understand abstraction
using Java code so for abstraction I'm
going to use a classic example using
bikes so let's create a new project file
new project next and I am going to name
it as abstraction so we have our main
function here so I'm going to create new
classes
so first class I'm going to create as
bike
second I'll create name of the bikes
Suzuki and to understand better let's
create one more Honda
so the bike and Zuki classes I'm gonna
make it as abstract class so to make
abstraction as you all know we have to
use a keyword abstract and even Suzuki
I'm going to use it as abstract so Honda
I'm going to leave it like this so that
we can use this in our main function
because we cannot use the objects of
abstract classes so that's why I'm going
to leave Honda without the abstraction
so we can use all the abstract classes
bike and Suzuki so let's start with the
coding in bike first I am going to
create a constructor
and I'm gonna write it as bike started
just for an instant so that you can
understand the concept better so next
I'm going to use three methods which are
abstract and which we cannot define
inside the abstract class so first I am
going to use abstract run we have to
give it a return thing if it's void
that's fine and next I'm going to use it
as stop
and one more let's say I'm gonna use it
as ABS NT braking system so the thing is
if I declare abstract method here I
cannot define it I cannot write anything
inside it I will show you at this so if
I want to write something in it
this will show an error see this red
line here so if I go on this there's a
bulb sign here delete method body make a
run not abstract so if I make abstract I
cannot define it defining of this class
will be in the different class that has
inherited the class bike so I'm going to
delete this body right now and we are
going to use these things so that you
can understand better so if I declare a
normal method for example I'll make
change gear so if I print anything here
it will not show an error bike changed
gear so this will not show an error
because the return function is first of
all void and this is not abstract so we
can declare and define each method
anywhere in the class but if it is an
abstract we can only declare it but not
define it so what we'll do with this run
stop and abs we are going to use these
methods into Suzuki and Honda so let's
go to Suzuki first so first I am going
to extend it for bike so that it can
inherit the methods of the bike extends
bike so now if I use void run
and just print the statement like
Suzuki is running now this will not show
another because I am defining the whole
function the abstract function or method
inside the class was ooky that I
inherited from the bike now to explain
better let me just use one more method
boiled stop and I am gonna print stopped
so now you must be wondering why I am
not using abs it's simple anti braking
system it's not there in Suzuki but it's
there in Honda so that is how a normal
abstraction works I can use run and
stopped in Honda as well but that will
override the program so I'm going to use
abs
Antti braking system in on
so with this we have completed our
program I mean all the classes so let's
get to our main program and see what we
can do here so first of all I cannot
create objects of the classes that are
abstract so if I create bike B is equal
to new bike this will not accept it
because if I go on here implement
methods this is an error you can see
their bike is abstract cannot be
initiated so for this I am going to use
Honda instead of bike I cannot use
Suzuki because Suzuki is also abstract
now this line is also red because I have
not extended Honda to Suzuki or either
bike so as per Honda I am going to
extend it to Suzuki
and yeah if I go to Maine program now
it's all fine because Honda has
inherited properties of Suzuki as well
as bike so after I create objects once I
use it like B dot run then B dot ABS v
dot change gear and B dot stop C I get
everything here all the full programs
that I declared in bike and defined in
Suzuki and Honda as well but I can use
all the programs because they have
inherited properties from there but I
cannot use that directly because of
abstraction so that is the main concept
of abstraction that we cannot see the
background details or the detailed
things that are running behind we can
see only the relevant details
so now let's stop it and let's run this
program
and yeah we have successfully executed
it see as the starting bike started
that's the constructor we called after
that suzuki is running it's in the run
function here then anti braking system
that's ABS then bike changed gear let's
change gear and Suzuki stopped that
stopped so with this we have completed
our code let's move on to our next topic
now let's see what is encapsulation
encapsulation is like a capsule the
whole code and data is bounded together
into a single unit consider this example
variables and method are defined inside
one class like a capsule other way to
think about encapsulation is it is
protective shield that prevents the data
from being accessed by the code outside
of this shield now let's see an example
of encapsulation using Java code so now
let's create a new project file new and
project next click the box next so I am
going to name it as encapsulation
finish so we have our main program here
so let's create a class for an
encapsulation
right-click on main new and Java class
for this I am going to name it as an cap
and enter so I have a class for
encapsulation
so let's declare some variables so let's
say I'm going to declare it as private
string name
so I'll create a profile of a student
who is studying so name age and rule
number I'll be requiring for it
so next variable will be private int age
next will be private int roll number so
now let's have getters and setters for
this program for this right click
generate getter and setter select all
and okay so we have all the getters and
setters for this program this is used to
easy the program so that we don't have
to go and type all these things so this
is a feature of Java that will be very
helpful so now let's go to the main
program and write our code here so in
the starting I am going to use one
object I'll use it as obj is equal to
new and cap so I have created our object
for the class end cap and now I'm going
to set the age name and roll number so
for this obj dot set age and I'm gonna
set it as 21 next one obj dot set to
rule number 11 and next obj dot set name
I'm gonna write my name as Luxur so now
we have set age new roll number and name
all the variables are set so now we have
to print these variables so for printing
we have a command system dot out dot
println so in this first I'll type the
name so now here obj dot not set name
but here I'm gonna get it as get name so
I'm going to copy this because I will be
requiring this for three times so I'll
just paste it after name I'll write roll
number so here it becomes get roll
and here age and here it becomes get age
so now we have completed our program so
now let's run it and yes we have our
program finished and compiled and
executed properly as you can see I have
named roll number and even age so this
is how encapsulation works so if I am to
use any of these variables name age or
olam bar in other classes I cannot do
that so that is the main part of
encapsulation and it is very secure so
with this we have completed our
encapsulation let's move on to our next
concept in Java
oops our thread concept is polymorphism
polymorphism means one task is performed
in different ways one function is used
for different tasks there are two
methods of polymorphism first method is
method overloading and second method
overriding method overloading occurs
when there are two or more methods of
the same name but with different
signatures method overriding occurs when
one method is super class that is
redefined in the subclass the signature
of method remains the same let's see
examples of both of them in method
overloading there is a function multi
that multiplies the variables inside it
so we can use different methods with
same name but we have to use different
arguments in this example first method
have integer a and integer B as
arguments the second method has double
data type a and b variables and third
method has three variables as arguments
in method overriding same method is used
at multiple places but each time it
executes the result is overwritten in
this example top speed method is used in
all the classes for BMW the result will
be 150 204 Rd and 184 Mercedes now let's
see examples now let's see each of these
examples using Java code
so in polymorphism the program will be
similar like inheritance but in
inheritance we inherit all the
properties variables as well as methods
but in polymorphism we use same methods
at different places so let's create a
new project
next and I'm going to name it as Bali
one so first I'm gonna use an use method
overloading that means using the same
functions at two different places so let
me just create a new project so let me
just create a new class and I'm gonna
name it as multiply so I'm gonna create
method with the same class name so here
in Tumulty and I'm gonna give arguments
int a comma into B and I am gonna return
the value a into B so now I'll create
one more method but with different
argument int multi and this time I'm
gonna give it as double
double a common BB and I am gonna return
a into B so it's showing red line
because instead of integer I need to
give double here so now I'm gonna give
one more
but with different arguments
a into B and in C and I am going to
return a into B into C so now I have
three methods of the same name all are
multi now how do I use it
the use depends on what I declare so now
I'm going to declare object for this
class multi
so now I'm gonna print the result of
these three functions or methods first I
have to declare two integers then two
doubles and then three integers so now
to print this s out m dot then I'm gonna
use multi and in this two comma three so
it automatically detects a and B so now
if I do m dot double comma double
so then double I have to put a decimal
point and as per B let's do it six point
six so as you can see it automatically
detects which function I am calling or
which method I am calling so according
to the arguments that I give it detects
its method so now as per three variables
three four and five so now if I execute
it and yeah you can see the result here
so our first was two comma three that
means 2 into 3 that's 6 second is three
point three a multiplied by six point
six that's 21 point seven seven nine and
the third one 3 into 4 into 5 that's 60
so I hope you understood the concept
behind polymorphism so now let's move on
to overriding so for this I'm going to
create a new project
and I'm gonna write it as polymorphism
second one so in this I have main
program so now I'm gonna create classes
for it so I'm going to use a classic
example for cars so first one let me
name car as BMW the second one Rd
and a third one Mercedes so as you saw
the example before when we were
discussing about what volume of ism is I
had an example where I use the method as
top speed so I'm gonna use top speed and
let Mercedes be 220 I'll just copy paste
it Rd I'm gonna make it as 200 and for
BMW
I'm gonna make it as 240 so now we have
three functions or methods top speed in
three different classes so now what will
happen if I use a normal method here so
now again I'm gonna create a interface
for the user so that he can choose which
car to use and yeah before that I'm
gonna create objects for these classes
so first BMW I'm gonna give it a scar 1
is equal to new BMW as per our D I'm
gonna give it a c2 and as per Mercedes
I'm gonna give it as c3
and yeah we have created all the objects
so now I'm gonna create one more
variable to get the input of the user
the same CH and now I'm going to ask the
user we have three models
again I'm gonna give them the menu first
one is BMW second one is Rd
and third oneness Mercedes and ask the
user what would you prefer so enter your
choice so again I'm gonna do a scanning
part so again as you all know I'm gonna
import Java dot util dot scanner so here
CH is equal to s dot next int now I have
to declare a variable for scanner so
scanner s is equal to new scanner system
dot in
so here s dot next int so now we have
choice of the user so if the user
chooses first one that means BMW so I am
going to write as top speed of BMW is
and then as BMW is car one saw
so C 1 dot top speed so it's going to
automatically return the value that is
there in BMW and again L safe if CH is
equal to U is equal to 2 then it gives
Rd so I am just going to copy paste this
sentence
and instead of Siwon I'm gonna make c2
and again if the user chooses three as
their option then I'm gonna give
Mercedes and instead of C 2 it will be C
3 so if the user gives an input that is
not irrelevant so for that else
please enter the value between 1 & 3 so
with this we have completed our program
so now let's run it and we have
successfully executed our program so BMW
Rd and Mercedes I'm gonna enter choice
as one that is BMW and yes we can see
top speed of BMW is 240 if we go into
the program I give 240 as the value so
it overrides the program the method that
I gave so if I again execute it and give
the value as 2 then the top speed
becomes 200 so this time I executed Rd
and the top speed that's there inside
the Rd class so now that we have
understood what polymorphism is let's
move on to the next topic now in the end
let's see what inheritance is when one
class inherits some properties and
attributes of other class it is known as
inheritance let's have a look at an
example in this example automobiles is a
super class that have methods like fuel
for fuel capacity year for year of
manufacture and speed for maximum speed
the classes that inherits the variables
and methods of automobiles are bikes
cars and planes these classes will be
called as subclass now let's see Java
code for this example so that we can
understand it better so now let's create
a new project file new project next tick
next and am gonna name it as inheritance
example finish so we have our main class
here so I am going to create some more
classes
first class I am going to use it as
automobiles
now inside automobiles there are many
classes so I'm gonna make first one as
bikes the second one I am gonna make it
as cars and the third one I'm gonna name
it as planes so bikes cars and planes
all of them extends automobiles means
they inherit properties from automobiles
so I'm gonna write extends automobiles
in everything
and in plains extends automobiles
so now bikes cars and planes inherit
everything that comes in automobiles so
now let's create some variables first
int year of manufacture second int
maximum speed as you saw in the example
and third one string fuel
I am putting fuel as string just because
I'm gonna put liters after that so how
much is the capacity of bike in liters
so for that L I have to put as string
otherwise I would go for a double or
integer so even for this if I mostly if
I don't extend it then I won't be able
to use these variables as it is but now
I have inherited the properties then I
can use them very easily so int here in
speed and string few
and same thing I'm gonna do here so I'll
just copy paste it
and same thing in planes so now we have
our variables ready so now let's go to
main program so if you need you can use
getters and setters for it as well
so here getter and setter select on and
okay now getters and setters are usually
helpful when he we have very big
programs and we need methods for it but
for this is a very simple program so i'm
i don't think so i'm gonna use getters
and setters it's just for your knowledge
so i'll just go to main program so in
the first i'm going to create all the
objects cars car is equal to new cars
verax bike is equal to new bikes and
planes plane is equal to new planes so
now we have created all the objects so
we need some user input as well so for
this I'm gonna import scanner and
declare object for scanner
Java dot util dot scanner so here
scanner s is equal to new scanner in
bracket system dot in so that is used
for input so now let's start declaring
all the values that we have created for
the objects so we'll start with car
carl dot here is equal to as a year was
end so i will make it as 2014 next car
dot speed our speed was also integer so
i'm going to take it as 180 kilometer
per hour or miles per hour it's all up
to you guys even you want to declare it
as string and make it as KMPS the or
kmph it's up to you
so car dot in the end fuel so fuel is
string so i'm going to use it as
inverted commas so usually car has
twenty liters so now same thing i'm
going to do it for bikes and planes bike
dot here is equal to let's give it as
2016 by dot speed i'll give it as 150
and by dot fuel i'm going to give it as
ten liters
ten liters and then the bike so all
three of bikes are also done so now it's
up to plane plane dot here is equal to
2018 plane dot speed now as you all know
plane travels much faster than car or
any bike so I am gonna give it as
thousand and plane dot fuel I'm gonna
give it as two hundred litres so now we
have declared all the values for our
variables so I'm gonna create a platform
where a user chooses whether he wants to
know the details about car bike or plane
so in the starting I'm going to ask user
that we have three models what would you
like to choose
so in three models I'm going to write it
as one cars
two bikes and three planes
and in the end I'm going to ask the user
to enter their choice
so choice for choice also I need one
more variable so I'm gonna declare int
CH and CH is equal to s dot next int as
it is an integer so we have a choice now
so if if the user chooses first one that
is cause
so I'm gonna print all the details of
cars
so first year of manufacture and plus
car dot year and I am just going to copy
paste it
so the next after year of manufacture it
comes maximum speed and after that in
the end fuel capacity
so same thing I'm gonna copy and I'm
going to move on to what if user chooses
the second thing so for this I am going
to use else--if statement CH is equal to
is equal to 2 that means if user chooses
to then I am going to just paste it so
ii was bike
bike
and bike dot do I think instead of here
I have to change it
everywhere I have put here so and I just
quickly change it car dot speed
and car dot fuel bike dot speed and bike
dot fuel
again copy and what if the user chooses
planes that means if the choice is equal
to 3 then have to paste the same thing
and but instead of bike I'll write plane
and plane dogs fuel so with this we have
completed our program but in case a user
enters invalid input either he enters
four or five or any of his number that
he wants so for this we have to use a
default thing that means we have to
print to the user that enter choice
between 1 and 3
so that's it we have completed our
program for inheritance so now let's run
it and yes we have successfully executed
our program so here it asked enter your
choice so in the starting I'm going to
go with bikes so I'm gonna put two and
yeah it can show me the year of
manufacture the maximum speed of bike
and the fuel capacity of the bike so we
I can make it more interesting with this
I'll just have to write off car
so so that the user can understand it
better so it's all the user interface
then how neatly you can create a program
and how neatly you can execute it so
that people will understand that is also
one useful part that we need
and in the last I'm gonna write it as of
plain
so now if I execute it so that looks
much neater and easy to understand right
so again I'm gonna put as bikes you can
also put it as bike but for your
understanding I'm gonna put it as planes
that means - my choice will be three and
enter and yeah Arif manufacture of plane
is 2018 max speed is thousand and fuel
capacity is 200 liters so with this we
have finished our program on inheritance
so this brings us to the end of the
video we learned about Java object
oriented programming and all its
concepts abstraction encapsulation
polymorphism and inheritance I hope you
liked the video thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turner up and get certified click
here